olha aí o pedal sou honesta nunca dançou
andrade esteves e aí ela é tudo bom a
gente é o seguinte hoje vai fazer um
tempo diferente é o seguinte é o desafio
que é o desafio tente não que esse
desafio eu vi no canal do dia chefe do
brasil e da carta mundo me tira de ver o
canal não negócio foi o robusta estou me
fazendo o que une que acontece o
seguinte o coxa por sua chance é é a
pessoa bota água na boca enche e é
preciso verificar por 30 segundo a na
boca enquanto a outra pessoa tem de
fazer a pessoa a pessoa tem que botar
água na boca pessoa que a pessoa pra
botar na boca eu que sou outra pessoa
tempo valeu brian afã de lucros que a
dulce praia não significa 15 espiado e
ganha e se eu conseguir os meus críticos
embutia yew assim o número 5 100
confiável ganho entendeu eu te digo bota
aí em algum medo
eu acertei meu primeiro filho no caso do
método deu confiança muito difícil tive
voz a votar já na ponte mas desde que a
lei vai obrigá lo a sair o menino tal
acusou a ii taça rio perdeu a primeira
no bico do peito
olha eu não entendia
[Aplausos]
é preciso voltar à moda ditada consegui
aguentar olha pra mim
ou seja não sabe que é uma uma velha no
meio da rua no chão
a minha adaptação do pet droga até 2 1º
de março mas a então voltei num toque é
um descartado
[Risadas]
porque me considero esta uma piada acho
que é eu ainda estava com a mãe
[Música]
[Risadas]
e velho chefe rj o veleiro bastante
significativo que isso é nossa é a rocha
[Aplausos]
sobre o cabelo está formado o mato e se
sabe até quando tá na mão da sua mãe
bola é do meu clube estava sendo nosso
encontro
mas cativante com pessoas saber da
eficiência normal no ano 2000 e que não
não dá disse
tudo seria uma menina super mulher
porque essas precisam da dança está no
palco rui parecer pelaipe meio ágil a
vaga uma vez que vc tava diz que sem
querer eu cair e tinha um tinha um não
sei por que o sexo que tinham legal pará
70 no chão e eu caiu em cima e tá no meu
carro até hoje é o rosa
adivinho escutou dragão
a garra que foi entendido de maio mostra
os jogos aqui vamos circo de saleh
[Música]
se você não tivesse vindo eu quero dizer
obrigado por você dá um light
ambos nunca foi tão gentil da laep nesse
vídeo casa chegou a ficar sentado
facebook fez por dia está no meio da rtl
estaria sob a fantasia a divulgação
porque após saber que você gostou e se
escreve o canal
se você quiser conhecer o canal do braia
é só sentar nessa toada a equipe aparece
na tela em branco vai ser exibido lá em
casa e pessoal parece
[Música]